I'm in Washington DC just a couple miles
down the road from the White House where
anti refugee policy is being written but
here this little falafel shop was
started to help refine a fed and food in
general is the ultimate equalizer and I
want to use for that to show the world
that refugees are real this is a food
that they're forced to eat because
they're poor and they don't have
opportunity falafel Inc opened just
three months ago but it's quickly become
one of the hottest lunch spots in the
upscale Georgetown neighborhood at only
three bucks for a falafel sandwich their
prices are hard to beat and so is their
mission for every dollar in revenue we
take in we donate a portion of that back
to the World Food Program who then
deploys it to refugees around the world
so with every meal that's purchased in
our restaurant one day's worth of food
is given to a refugee ahmed akkad is a
Palestinian American entrepreneur and
founder of falafel Inc what surprised me
most since we've opened for that Inc
which has only been about 90 days is the
community's warm embrace meant of our
product our culture and our mission
there's another mission that's just as
important to him and that's preserving
his Palestinian cultural heritage it's
our food the falafel of Hamas it's our
heritage ania and it's very important to
me is to revitalize
Palestinian he swears his stuff is the
real deal honestly our foods the bomb I
would take our falafel Hamas tabbouleh a
subtle thought over frankly anyone's in
America and as good as those that you
get a man a Philistine but these are all
my tats as recipes I mean grandma
customers I talk to bouts for the
authenticity
and I want like taste my seeds or my
mamas about game I come here that's the
closest thing I know and all of details
so people ask me all the time like how
do you make that outfit a face so
authentic and the finesse are just like
back home and it's basic we have back
home equipment equipment like this
falafel wok which was imported from a
Palestinian refugee camp in Gaza I think
about the temperature of people in
refugee camps with hot summer you know
frying for that but not because we're
having fun but because it's a means of
survival falafel Inc motto is eat with
dignity part of our business model is to
literally hire recruit train and
scale-up refugees Salameh the kind of
employee Ahmed likes hiring economic
insecurity and violence in her home
country of Honduras drove her to leave
for the US last year in search of a
better and safer life ok
take a supersonic EMF anesthetic on
ayuda para me this unit as a fat suit
four four four
while we were filming the Trump
administration announced that it's
lowering the number of refugees that
will be allowed to enter the US next
year to no more than 45,000 that's the
lowest cap in decades so our refugee
definition goes beyond those that are
just doing war we look at people who are
seeking better economic opportunities
also climate change you've seen the
disasters which have happened with the
hurricane just over in the last week or
two in President Trump
welcome you here at Flacco Inc everyone
is welcome at for that fitting hey guys
it's Deena and the food out for lack of
Inc was really good and their mission to
help refugees is incredible I covered
the refugee crisis in Europe in 2015 and
earlier this year you can check out
those videos and be sure to like comment
and share and subscribe
[Music]